to france where the government's dropped
a controversial draft law that would
restrict the publishing of images of
police
the bill sparked large protests on
saturday
fueled by anger over a video of police
beating a black man in paris
critics of the law say it could prevent
such incidents from being exposed
and a new version of the bill will now
be submitted more from natasha butler in
paris on the significance of this
proposal
it's clear that the government has been
forced to make a concession
because mps have said that they are
going to
rewrite the controversial uh clause
in their planned new security law now
this clause is controversial
because what it does is it would crack
down on people's ability to
publish share broadcast images of police
officers on duty the government says
that that would help protect the
identity of police officers who often do
difficult work
but opponents of this clause say that it
is
an erosion of press freedoms it's an
erosion of
the right to inform of people's right of
expression and that without
images of police officers or duty police
will not be able to be
accountable for their actions at a time
where we're seeing
several officers being accused of police
brutality especially
over the past few days now the
government of course
forced to make a concession i can say
that but on the other hand i think it's
really important
to keep it in perspective because over
the last few days the government has
indicated it might
rewrite the article of this clause but
what does rewrite mean no one has
actually
made that very clear and i think what
many uh uh
people who are watching this very
closely say is that the problem is
that most people who are against it the
many uh politicians on
all sides of the spectrum really and
protesters tens of thousands of them
who are in the streets on saturday what
they want is the government to just
withdraw this article altogether